rien n'est perdu aux éditions de
l'Observatoire vraiment Natacha Polonie
dans ce recueil de vos meilleures
chroniques 2018 2023 vous refusez la
fatalité d'un pays qui se perdrait dans
le déclin on voit ça dans l'invitation
Marco Pomier on en parle toutes les deux
juste après si on vous invite Natacha
Polonie c'est parce que dans ce monde
brutal anxiogène Daras à Bruxelles en
passant par Israël ou Gaza sans oublier
l'Ukraine ou l'urgence climatique vous
faites entendre votre voix en affirmant
que rien n'est perdu un peu de
positivité voilà je pense je pense que
nous ne devons pas nous laisser aller
collectivement à la dépression les
solutions elles elles existent un
partiprix étonnant pour une
éditorialiste antionformiste aux
constats alarmants sur l'immigration
l'écologie ou encore l'école votre sujet
de prédilection on vous dit pessimiste
et décliniste queenenny je crois en la
France répondez-vous une conviction
forgée peut-être auprès de la jeunesse
durant votre passage éclair au lycée
d'épiné sur scène en tant que professeur
de lettre tout à l'heure vous disiez la
langue française parfois a trop de mots
dire j'ai faim c'est
j'ai on va manger même si on dit je suis
affamé ou j'ai faim on va manger le
résultat il est le même si vous dites je
suis affamé c'est beaucoup plus fort
comme mot indéiablement Natacha Polonie
vous savez manier le verbe essayiste
journaliste à La plus maasséré au
service du Figaro Europe 1 France 2 BFM
TV ou encore C8 aujourd'hui directrice
du magazine Marianne antilibéral
favorable à la décroissance et
souverainiste le temps vous a plutôt
donné raison sur ce point alors que la
France se réindustrialise doucement
après le fiasco du covid manque de blous
pour les médecins manque de masque un
électrochoc la désindustrialisation de
la France dont les chantres de la
mondialisation se moquaent comme d'une
guigne est devenu le nouveau passage
obligé de tout discours politique
combattre le néolibéralisme appelé à une
révolution démocratique dénoncer
l'écologie du symbole un livre et des
éditau pour critiquer le système actuel
mais puisque rien n'est perdu Natacha
Polonie on a une question pour vous
quelles sont les raisons
d'espérer réponse quelles sont les
raisons d'espérer bah la France et les
Français parce que c'est un pays qui a
des ressources une richesse des tout
simplement une énergie vous savez
j'étais hier par exemple à la remise des
Trophées des cantines rebelles
c'est-à-dire des petites municipalités
qui font passer leur cantines en bio en
local et qui se battent pour rendre ça
gratuit pour les gamins vous avez là
mais des gens qui se battent pour leur
pays là dans 2 semaines ça va être le
salon du madeine France allez-y ça vous
met une pêche extraordinaire il y a que
des gens fabuleux qui se battent qui
monent des entreprises qui ont qui sont
inventifs elle est là l'énergie donc
c'est les Français avant tout alors je
vous propose parce que c'est des
chroniques et donc ça brosse
parfaitement les 6 ans de mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron quelques photos on va
commencer par le président de de la
République Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il
a en 6 ans puisque vous retracez à
travers toutes ces chroniques toute
l'actualité changé de logiciel la
startup nation le néolibéral du début
s'est-il muté en protectionniste en tout
cas le mot n'est plus tabou dans sa
bouche c'est extraordinaire ni le mot
protection Enfin le mot souveraineté
c'est fabuleux tout il a radicalement
changé parce que tout simplement il
s'est pris le le réel en pleine figure
donc il a changé dans les termes la
question et de savoir si au pied du mur
il y a vraiment des actes parce que moi
je suis ravi des gens qui font leur
chemin de Damas qui se convertissent
c'est beau je suis tant mieux hein moi
j'accueille je TR très
bien exactement on va on va on va
recréer de de l'industrie ici on va
essayer de protéger des filières et
cetera c'est formidable le nucléaire
enfin il a quand même il a quand même
flingué il a eu en partie alors il est
pas tout seul hein il y avait eu
François Hollande avant mais il a
flingué la filière nucléaire il a
continué puis il a arrêté le projet le
projet Astrid qui était un projet de
recyclage des déchets mais maintenant ça
il se reconverti là aussi on a mais quel
temps perdu donc le problème là-dedans
c'est l'absence de de structure
d'architecture de logiciel parce que
pour défendre des idées face à tous les
les intérêts qui vont se coaliser
c'est-à-dire que on est dans un monde où
vous avez des grands intérêts des
multinationales qui qui ont intérêt à ce
que le système reste tel qu'il est pour
résister à cela il faut se battre il
faut avoir des convictions c'est pas
simplement l'air du temps il est trop
plastique en fonctionattend du contexte
sil de discours tout tout le temps
a-t-il tiré les leçons de la crise des
gilets jaunes mar a énormément travaillé
sur ce mouvement qui à vos yeux est un
véritable tournant majeur dans le pays
les gilets jaunes qui évidemment
manifestait pour le pouvoir d'achat mais
aussi pour une véritable demande
démocratique d'être associé à la
décision est-ce que les choses ont
changé depuis ou se sont
aggravées je pense que la crise
démocratique on l'a tous vu elle s'est
aggravée elle se perpétue et j'ai
l'impression en effet vous me demandiez
si Emmanuel Macron avait compris je ne
crois pas et je crains qu'en fait les
gens qui sont les bénéficiaires de ce
système économique n'arrivent pas à
entendre ce que c'est que l'aspiration
démocratique la démocratie c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple ça ne signifie pas que
une technocratie sait les choses mieux
que ces crétins qui ont le droit de vote
donc on est obligé de temps en temps de
faire semblant et qu'on va faire le
bonheur leur bonheur malgré eux ce
quelle est la nature du divorce entre le
peuple et ses représentants puisqu'on
est ici à la Assemblée nationale sur la
Chaîne Parlementaire est-ce que ces
représentants ont échoué dans leur
mission ou est-ce qu'ils rejettent tous
les corps intermédiaires jusqu'à leurs
propres élus je pense que c'est une
défiance qui s'est petit à petit étendue
et c'est pour ça que il y a une urgence
c'estàd que réellement aujourd'hui la
démocratie est en danger parce que vous
avez un pan entier des de du pays qui a
fait ses cessions c'est-à-dire qui cesse
d'y croire qu'il ne votent plus pourquoi
bah parce qu'ils ont l'impression que
quel que soit leur vote ça ne change
rien c'est-à-dire que le système se
perpétue et quand je dis le système se
perpétue c'est ce qu'on appelle le
néolibéralisme c'est-à-dire ce phénomène
qui depuis 40 ans a justement contourné
tous les tous les outils démocratiques
par des instances supranationales l'OMC
les évidemment l'Union européenne telle
qu' est
c'est
europeque euréen de 86 et l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui l'Europe d'après covid
l'Europe d'après crise financière qui a
réussi à faire la planche à billet
sortir des traités aujourd'hui qui
relève les taux d'intérêt face à
l'inflation qui achète des vaccins
stupidité entre nous relever les taux
d'intért question sur cette Europe
d'aujourd'hui qui s'apprête à harmoniser
les règles de migration est-ce qu'elle a
changé en mieux ou pas pour vous alors
là aussi c'est comme avec Emmanuel
macronon il y a face évidemment au mur
du réel une prise de conscience il y a
certaines choses qui ont changé et en
tout cas les discours ont très
clairement changé c'est-à-dire que on
peut désormais dire que l'Europe doit
protéger on peut désormais se dire que
l'Europe doit être une une puissance
politique et pas seulement un grand
marché ouvert à tous les vents et
uniformisé c'est déjà pas mal mais
concrètement le problème de l'Union
européenne c'est que elle a changé de
nature ce n'est pas celle de 1957 qui
était faite pour préparer la préférence
communautaire c'est-à-dire on se protège
autour et on libéralise à l'intérieur à
partir de l' de l'Acte Unique l'ensemble
des traités sont en fait euh faits pour
valider un système de dérégulation et
aujourd'hui la difficulté c'est ça quand
vous interrogez des entrepreneurs il
vous vous expliquent qu'en fait c'est
une mise en concurrence totale et
l'élargissement empêche au fur et à
mesure les outils
démocra encore à un nouvel élargissement
quand même est-ce que vous vous avez
énormément travaillé sur euh les ravages
de la mondialisation le creusement des
inégalité l'Europe d'aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'elle a réalisé ça pour vous est-ce
que c'est déjà le meilleur échelon pour
vous pour essayer de de combattre ça
premièrement je pense que on n pas
trouvé de meilleur échelon que celui qui
est l'échelon de la démocratie
c'est-à-dire l'État nation pour
l'instant l'Europe sera sans doute un
jour un échelon véritablement
démocratique pour l'instant c'est trop
éloigné il y a trop de strat et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que vous avez une
guerre de pouvoir entre oursoua van
derleyen à la tête de la commission et
et les États-membres tout simplement et
leurs représentants au sein du Conseil
de l'Europe donc on voit bien que il y a
une tentative pour essayer petit à petit
de voilà la guerre en Ukraine évidemment
très présente dans le livre véritable
déflagration pour la France pour
l'Europe on a dû se priver du du gaz
russe avec les conséquences qu'on
connaît on vous reproche parfois votre
anti-américanisme qui vous aurait
conduit à une forme d'aveuglement sur
Vladimir Poutine qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça que si vous regardez mes
écr
j'ai toujours considéré Vladimir Poutine
comme un type dangereux épouvantable un
dictateur et franchement je n'ai jamais
eu la moindre tendresse par pourquoi
parce que tout simplement depuis tout à
l'heure je vous parle de démocratie je
vous parle de donner le pouvoir au
peuple il est le contraire de ça en
revanche ce n'est pas parce qu'on
déteste ce qu' l' incarne et son et et
sa façon de de détruire petit à petit
l'ensemble des outils démocratiques et
la société russe c'est c'est pas parce
qu'on déteste ça qu'il faut s'aveugler
sur le fait qu'il y a un retour des
empires qu'il y a un jeu géopolitique
qu'il y a une guerre de l'information et
je pense que la seule question qu'on
doit se poser face à un conflit aussi
atroce dont Vladimir Poutine est
coupable on est bien d'accord c'est lui
qui qui envahit et c'est l'Ukraine qui
est victime ça il y a pas de débat
là-dessus en revanche le débat c'est de
savoir comment on combat ça et comment
on fait en sorte que les Européens
puissent préserver leur sécurité face à
justement des empires qui leur passent
par-dessus la tête parce que le problème
des États-Unis c'est qu'ils ont été dans
depuis deux ou trois décennies fauteur
de guerre absolument partout et qu'ils
ont fait des catastrophes et que ce ne
sont jamais eux qui payent le prix de
ces catastrophes ce sont les peuples
quels qu'ils soi très souvent d'ailleurs
en Afrique au moyen avec un Jo Biden
hier qui quand même avertit netaniaou à
ne pas refaire les erreurs américaines
d'après le 11 septembre je voudrais
qu'on termine très très V parce que nos
affrochés nous attendent et vous allez
réagir à leur partieprix Marine Le Pen
pour revenir en France son ascension
est-elle arrêtable oui rien n'est perdu
non mais bien sûr là aussi rien n'est
perdu pourquoi parce que encore faut-il
comprendre ce qui fait monter Marine Le
Pen ce qui fait monter Marine Le Pen
c'est l'impression chez beaucoup de
citoyens que ce système les écrase et
qu'ils n'ont pas de prise mais répondons
au problème est-ce que depuis 6 ans
qu'Emmanuel Macron est au pouvoir
l'école va mieux est-ce que la santé va
mieux est-ce que les services publics
vont mieux est-ce que les transports le
train va mieux est-ce qu'il y a eu un
véritable aménagement du territoire
est-ce qu'il y a eu une politique du
logement quand quand on fera ça et bien
je peux vous assurer que les gens
n'éprouveront pas le besoin de voter
pour le rassemblement national parce
qu'au fond d'ux ils en ont pas forcément
envie vous restez avec moi Natacha
Poloni rien n'est perdu vous l'avez
compris c'est du Polonie purju c'est à
lire aux éditions de l'Observatoire